toutes nos ventes sont taxés va aviver
us chez ce concessionnaire mitsubishi de
boucherville on ne vend pratiquement
plus de voitures lire la plupart veulent
tout un pays vers saint-jean garder
l'espace le chargement le camping la
famille le sport la sécurité beaucoup de
raisons poussent les consommateurs à
acheter de plus gros véhicules le côté
pratique le fait qu'on peut juste
souvent les familles se payer un
véhicule qui est capable de faire à peu
près tout avec deux sièges d'enfants
l'arrière ne peut pas décemment
fonctionner avec une sous compacte même
s'ils se sont beaucoup des petits
véhicules utilitaires stars qui sont
populaires l'impact sur les émissions de
co2 n'est pas négligeable
c'est vrai que les petits vs où même les
plus gros v8 ils ont fait des grosses
améliorations en termes de consommation
d'essence le problème c'est qu'on
devrait consommer moins pourtant
l'environnement est au coeur des
préoccupations
l'environnement c'est un enjeu qui vous
touche pour exactement exactement
écouter regarder cherche aujourd'hui on
est à fait doute mais surtout
l'environnement en première place votre
véhicule vous l'avez choisi comme un
drame
aussi pour le camping j'ai une roulotte
on tire la roulotte avec si l'enjeu
prioritaire de la campagne selon les
utilisateurs de la boussole électorale
de radio canada une certaine
contradiction je pense que ça fait
partie de la nature humaine 1 mais le
gouvernement fédéral toute la légitimité
pour intervenir en matière de changement
climatique il faut s'attaquer au secteur
du transport un des plus polluants au
canada et au québec et qui est en
croissance ce sont des choix de
consommation ce sont des choix qui sont
conditionnés qui sont conditionnées
notamment par le prix puis le
gouvernement fédéral une taxe d'accise
sur les véhicules énergivores mais cet
axe là elle est largement inefficace
en 2019 qu'ils étaient des centaines de
milliers a demandé plus d'action pour
lutter contre les changements
climatiques
albert lalonde était parmi les
organisateurs de la mobilisation
je pense qu'on n'a pas le choix de
continuer les signer son époque ce qu'on
a l'urgence climatique est toujours
aussi actuel malgré une pandémie et une
mobilisation moins visibles il milite
toujours même s'ils croient qu aucun
parti politique ne va assez loin pour la
planète les gens veulent de l'action en
environnement savent pas exactement
c'est ça implique mais on veut je pense
aussi qu'il ya très très peu
d'initiatives la part des gouvernements
pour vraiment mettre en lumière des
solutions
parce que devant un problème si vaste il
faut du courage politique selon pierre
olivier pineau les parties sont très
limitées dans les propositions agressive
et efficace qui pourrait mettre de
l'avant parce que ses propositions pour
qu'elle fonctionne vraiment un point
devrait forcément impliquer une
contrainte ou une limite ou un frais
supplémentaires et ça ça passe très mal
dans l'électorat qui est important c'est
de mettre en oeuvre des mesures qui vont
avoir de véritable impact sur les choix
et pratiques des individus un exercice
délicat pour les partis politiques
issigeac audrey charbonneau raid au
canada
mon frère